I can't think of another actor who has
got so many catchphrases all your movies
seem to come with a catchphrase and in
the book it's British so you explain how
a little favor the I'll be back nearly
didn't happen
well I somehow had a problem when I
tried to say I'll be back
did I all sounded weird to me so I said
that the director said I think that I
would say I will be back and he says no
I think that I wrote I'll be back I said
by the mean listen to it I said I'll in
the Terminator doesn't talk like that
the Terminator will say I will be back
and he says look let's make it simple I
said I don't tell you how to act but
don't you tell me how to write and
that's what you say you say I'll be back
and I'm so happy that he insisted and
the I'll be back because when I when the
movie came out you never know when you
do the scene that there is going to be a
famous line or that it will be repeated
over and over so I remember when if the
movie came out someone stopped me in New
York and said Arad stay the line say the
line is a wood line this is the movie
from Germany this is you know the I'll
be back line they said I'll be back
is it the way you said I'll be back
[Applause]
people come up and say say the line I
lied
say the line glass all say the line so
you can be as you say I have a lot of
those lines that are now some of the
most quoted lines you know it's terrific
it's an honor but you never know ahead
of time so you can't force it like in
the movies you're doing now do you kind
of look I think sometimes you're wrong
no one repeats it and then other times
this is the line in that you never even
thought about I remember there was in
predator I think it was I ran by a guy
there we were and an attack on a village
we did occupied by come punch of
communist soldiers and they were trying
to kill us and we're trying to kill them
and they run by one and over said and I
hear you know about to kill me
he was reloading the gun and I just
heard a kick that pulled out my knife
and stick him in the chest pin him to
the pole that the knife went right
through him and I said them stick around
[Music]
so sure enough there was like everyone
asked me after the moving save the line
[Music]